for some of us today like every day
we'll mean another case of immersing
ourselves from the moment we wake up in
a by now very familiar set of painful
thoughts we will dwell once again on how
awful we look and more particularly on
how our nose is repulsively proportioned
relative to the rest of our face we will
think once again of a website we
inadvertently visited 12 years ago and
how the police might be preparing to
close in on and arrest us we will think
once again of how several of our
neighbors especially the people upstairs
might be colluding to ruin and disgrace
or we will think once again of something
we said to a colleague which we fear
they misconstrued and which may well
lead them to seek disciplinary action
against us at any moment these thoughts
May ostensibly be about a variety of
topics but beneath the surface they have
two key features in common they are
about something appalling we feel we are
or have done or there about something
appalling we fear that others are about
to do to us we are the victims of one of
the cruelest and most remorseless of all
mental afflictions obsessive thinking
crucially obsessive thinking is not
despite the linguistic proximity to be
confused with thinking per se it
certainly looks on the surface as though
the obsessive thinker is thinking a lot
all they might be drawing up dense
charts and jutting down intricate
matters in a notebook they might want to
leave a party early or Escape family
life in order to go to their room to
think they might have become near World
experts in plastic surgery or police
surveillance techniques or an area of
employment law they would be able to
tell you everything about tracking
devices post-operative skin treatments
and the minute-by-minute developments in
a specific aspect of the media agenda
the citation may be extreme but we may
still want to resist calling any of this
thinking as obsessive thinkers we're not
making progress through anything of note
we're not advancing through a dilemma
we're not clearing up a priority we are
thinking in order not to think by which
is meant we are using one kind of
thought to ward off another we are
employing obsessive thinking as a
defense against thinking more laterally
and emotionally about who we are and
what's happened to us against knowing
ourselves properly to try to break the
agonizing Loops in our minds we might
try to ask ourselves a deceptively
simple sounding question if we could not
think about our chosen topic if we were
to be debarred from returning to our
favored theme what might we think about
what other thoughts might lie behind or
to the side of our entrenched ritualized
preoccupations our minds are unlikely to
yield a neat answer but we can Hazard a
generalization if we could not think
about our obsessive topic we would most
likely need in one way or another to
feel intensely overwhelmingly sad lonely
desperate or bereft behind the
monomaniacal thoughts about cameras or
data packets or legal process or social
media There is almost always an
extremely frightened isolated unloved
child who long ago could not bear to
inhabit their own experience obsessive
patterns of thinking have gripped
themselves remorselessly to the walls of
the Mind in order to prevent a tragic
reencounter with an early highly
vulnerable and hurt version of
oneself in a bid for Relief we should
Dare for once to risk not returning to
our usual themes and instead while
conceding that this is what we might be
doing to stop running we should pause
where we are and leave our secondary
thoughts time to count catch up with us
we should put down our fixations and let
the waves of our background grief and
fear wash over us however tightly we've
Associated our problems with our favored
topic of scrutiny there's almost
certainly long been something bigger
older and more tragic that we've been
unable to look at that we were perhaps
maltreated by a caregiver that our
parents chronically preferred a sibling
to us that a father humiliated us
repeatedly to overcome his shame at his
own sexual abuse we have at an
unconscious level made a desperate
choice to think ill of ourselves or to
worry about plots against us in order to
impose a degree of logic on an otherwise
impossibly confounding early experience
of neglect or betrayal to an
indigestible experience of
untrustworthiness to a failure of love
our minds May gradually have an
opportunity to grow less consumed by
obsessive thoughts the more we can
interpret our preoccupations as symptoms
of other concerns we are in flight from
the more we can give up our feelings of
persecution and guilt in favor of a
sadder slower older truth about
ourselves that we were very badly let
down
indeed